Speaker 1: Let's try Colin from Oregon. Colin,
welcome to the show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: David, can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, thank you. Please.
Speaker 3: Hey, I appreciate the previous caller.
I'd like to ask you some questions about Sentinel.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now, is it fentanyl or
is it fentanyl the way Donald Trump says?
Speaker 3: Honest. I honestly don't know. No, I.
Speaker 1: Think it's I think it's
fentanyl. You pronounced it beautifully.
Speaker 3: Oh, I appreciate that. So I read
a lot of stuff just like everybody else does. And
the reports that are more more recent are saying,
well, China is producing sentinel and they're
shipping it to South America. And these immigrants
are pouring through our borders. Right. Bringing
fentanyl. But the truth the honest truth is we
have seen fentanyl in all 50 states. Yes.
So it's getting here somehow. The thing is,
I missed. I was misled. I thought, actually,
maybe there are some people in our country that
are producing fentanyl and distributing it.
What can we do to stop the flow of fentanyl?
Speaker 1: You know, this is a very complex
issue that clearly is not going to be solved
with a wall on the US-Mexico border. Now,
it is true that the primary source countries
for fentanyl and related substances that are
trafficked to the U.S. are Mexico and China.
India is increasingly a source for both the
finished fentanyl, but also some of the precursor
chemicals. There are seizures at the border. But
we need to be looking at ports of entry, including
airports. And and you also have to be considering
that if you fix the issue, as it might be seen,
fixing it right, using the language of the drug
war, if you fix the issue of the fentanyl that's
trafficked in. You then incentivize the domestic
production. So then you have to figure that out.
So I don't think there's a simple solution,
but what I can tell you is the issue isn't
something Biden did at the US-Mexico border.
Speaker 3: Right. They're saying that, well,
if we just close the border,
right. We could stop the the
the the what's the word, the metaphor of
immigrants pouring in. Do we really think
that immigrants is it. I mean, the numbers the
numbers did increase when Biden took over. The
numbers of immigrants did increase. But of
course, we also said we won't separate your
kids from your parents anymore. Yeah, but try to.
Speaker 1: You have to consider. Would that call
in as the oftentimes these right wingers cite the
increased number of apprehensions as evidence that
more people are coming in? But remember that
those people are being apprehended. There's a
different case to be made, which is, oh,
maybe Joe Biden is having a better job
done at the border where we are apprehending
more people and fewer are getting in. Now,
I'm not saying it is that way, but when the right
likes to use just that metric, it's kind of it's
quite dumb actually, to just use that metric.
Speaker 3: And I've talked to many right
wingers and I said, you know, that they used a
border wall campaign fund to lift up millions
of people and raise a few million dollars.
And they're like, What? And I'm like, Yeah,
you didn't hear about that.
Speaker 1: Oh, you mean
the the ban and build the wall thing?
Speaker 3: Yeah. They think that that
Trump didn't get to build
the wall. And the thing is,
he could have. And what they said was that what
they say is, like Biden said no and stopped
all procedures and there's just fence line
just standing by. So I don't. Is that true?
Speaker 1: I honestly, I'm not sure. It's hard
for me to keep track of all of the different
claims that that they make. But all of the
ones I've looked into so far have not been
accurate. But that one I'm just not familiar with.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I live in a pretty conservative.
I'm trying to make I try to make middle ground
with a lot of these folks around here. They told
me this, and I think it's hard and it's just
what you do when you get just gallops, when
they're like, look at all these and you go, okay,
I can only take this one at a time. Right. But the
most of the responses that I get are largely just
like I like a shock, like you said, shot out of a
cannon. It's so many different discussions all at
once, like Mike Lindell, it's too much. And this.
Speaker 1: You know, Sam Harris, love him or hate
him, he has a really good podcast on this where he
explains why he won't like debate Bret Weinstein
on vaccines because he said the problem is, you
know, these folks can very easily come in and set
like ten small fires and you might only have the
tools to put out nine of them. And they go, Yeah,
but didn't you see that study from like Bangladesh
where they like Ivermectin cured everything?
And then you're like, Well, no, I didn't see it,
but now you can't respond. Then it becomes a mass.
Speaker 3: I think lose, lose. It's not just yeah,
it's not a discussion that's taking place.
You're not having a good faith discussion.
It's a I have the whole alpha male. I have
to win this discussion. I have to win this
argument instead of maybe understanding you
might be actually wrong about something.
Speaker 1: Right? Absolutely. Collin, you
could possibly set it any better anyway.
Speaker 3: So I want to say I'm grateful
for your show. I'm grateful for you.
Thank you so much. And have a nice day.
Speaker 1: You too, and have a good holiday.
And are are you doing turkey? Are you doing
multiple roast chickens? What are you doing?
Speaker 3: Our family's very diverse. We're
just kind of we're doing a plethora of
options. I know. We're doing, like a smoked
mac and cheese. Wow. I don't know. Yeah,
I don't know if you're into that.
Speaker 1: Are you smoking it with
cherry wood or what are you smoking with?
Speaker 3: Oh, we have a trigger. We just,
you know, it's just a recipe. We never tried
it before, but you got you baked the thing and
then you you smoke on a trigger. Absolutely.
Speaker 1: You're not going to use like liquid
smoke, though. You'll use real smoke.
Speaker 3: Oh, absolutely.
Speaker 1: Okay, good. I knew
I could tell from just talking
to you. You would never resort to that.
Speaker 3: Sir. Sir, I have high standards when
it comes to culinary science. Thank you, Colin.
Speaker 1: Have a great holiday. Great to hear
from you. Let's go next. It's great to check
in and see see what everybody's plans are.